[Music]
now I want to introduce our first
keynote speaker who essentially is the
mastermind of Azure and Azure is kind of
the way we kind of draw boxes around of
these things so Azure is of course our
public cloud but a joke Azure stack is
also our private cloud and the two
together form the the the hybrid cloud
and asier is also our IOT or edge story
with the smaller devices and so the
mastermind behind that is mark
russinovich who is the CTO of
asia he he got his PhD from Carnegie
Mellon University and since then has had
a very fruitful career with many many
activities so he's really passionate
about distributed systems about security
about operating systems his he's been
working on Windows and Asia obviously
for a long time and he has created many
tools so he's the he's the author of the
SIS integration administration tools for
Windows he is the he had several stints
among others at IBM but in 1996 he he
started a company called winter nuts
which was eventually acquired by
Microsoft in 2006 and since 2006 he he
has been with Microsoft and has created
essentially helped create a sure and and
and holding Asha together one of the
very interesting fact facts about Mark
is that he's a very passionate speaker
but also a very passionate author and he
wrote books not only technical books but
also fictional books and fictional kind
of technical fictional books and and I
have
read them but I've now I have to three
books but I've actually looked in it say
I'm and I'm gonna read one of them and
you could you can look them up so with
that please welcome mark russinovich
thank you very much
excellent so I'm really disappointed to
hear he hasn't read him well anyway
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
to be here I want to thank MSR for
inviting me to kick this off faculty
research summit I'm the chief technology
officer of azor I've been in Azure for
eight years and in that role I work on
the technical strategy and architecture
for the platform now this morning I've
got about an hour with you and the topic
of this session is Azure architecture as
your architecture has grown over the
last ten years since azure was really
started to become a very broad and
complicated platform and so 60 minutes
is certainly not enough time to do it
justice I can give you a superficial
look at the architecture kind of the
broad brushstrokes but I thought it in
the process I'd also share with you
insights into some of the collaborations
we've had going with Microsoft research
I think Microsoft research in my view is
a competitive advantage we have here at
Microsoft having this research body
where people are off exploring sometimes
what we think are crazy ideas but then
proved to be interesting and we actually
have incorporated many of these ideas
we've partnered very deeply with them
across a number of different projects
and so during this architecture overview
I'm going to weave in some of those
projects and show how they've impacted
Adger so Microsoft data centers let me
talk a little bit about the overall data
center strategy which is to divide the
world into geographies we divide the
world into geographies largely based on
data sovereignty boundaries and more and
more we see customers wanting Azure data
centers within their country because of
their regulatory requirements data
sovereignty requirements of businesses
to have the data within the country
boundaries and so this is why we're now
at 54 regions worldwide across a number
of different geographies and when we go
into one of these geographies we go in
with at least two regions
these regions are defined by a latency
envelope of less than two milliseconds
so going from any data center to any
other data center within what we call a
region what we exposed to customers is
less than two milliseconds the region
pairs we call them are two regions that
are designed for customers to be able to
build a disaster recovery solution on
top of any of our services that support
geo data replication are required to
support replication between the geo
pairs although they can replicate to
other regions as well the distance
between them is typically several
hundred miles because we want to place
them far enough apart to survive
large-scale disasters so large
hurricanes large earthquakes floods but
within the region we actually divide the
region into availability zones
availability zones give customers the
ability to create a highly available
solution on top of data centers that can
fail so data centers we see can have
power outages they can have local floods
and fires they can also be impacted by
other environmental conditions in the
area and so we typically place the data
centers that make up these availability
zones several kilometers apart at least
the requirement there again is that
they've got the latency envelope between
the data centers that the region has and
less than two milliseconds enables
customers to build solution that
synchronously replicates data across the
data centers such that a service that
uses quorum to commit data durable data
like our storage services or our
database service can replicate the data
across three availability zones and
that's our minimum that we go into a
region with when we light up with
availability zones and then they can
tolerate the loss of a full availability
zone or the data centers associated with
it and still continue to serve write
operations they can actually tolerate -
and still continue to serve read data
off of their service now this is the
high level strategy I thought that's
always fun to take a look at actual
pictures of data centers and so I've got
something to share with you just to show
you the kind of scale that we're getting
to the amount of capital and
now Microsoft is putting into our data
center build-out around the world is on
the order of 10 billion dollars and this
is likely to grow Microsoft Azure has
doubled over the last few years and this
is a statement that we make publicly
about the compute usage doubling you can
talk you can see just our later latest
quarterly earnings call we announced
eighty nine percent year-over-year
growth of azure revenue and that
corresponds to the build outs that we've
got going with these data centers this
one is in Quincy Washington here's
another look at that from a different
angle where you can see the eight data
centers that I just showed you in the
picture there towards the receding
horizon and then you can see another
data center here in the foreground
Quincy is a great place because it's
served by renewable energy from the
Columbia River and there's plenty of
land of course there and we actually
offer data center tours there so
sometime if you come to campus it's
about a three-hour drive out there but
then you can go and take a look and walk
through one of our data centers here's
Cheyenne Wyoming this is another area
where we've got plenty of land energy
water to expand and you can see that
we've got massive expansion going on in
that area land being cleared for
additional data centers there
this is Dublin Ireland another place
where we've got massive data centers
there's actually six in this picture
there's three there on the left and
three there on the right it's building
out over time and we'll continue to
build new ones there as well Amsterdam
is another site Amsterdam is actually
has plenty of great water very reliable
energy and you can see here we've
cleared land for data center there's a
data center in front of us that building
off to the left looks like it might be a
data center it's actually not a data
center anybody know what that is it's a
greenhouse and that means it can be
growing one of two crops both of them
legal in the state of Washington
and then here's another look at
Amsterdam that building that we were
looking at is off there on the bottom
right so you can see that this is taken
slightly after that previous picture so
those data centers have been built out
and there's more land being cleared for
new data centers now one of the projects
that we're looking at with Microsoft
Research and this is one you know Donna
was talking about Microsoft research
goal is to surprise us and this one
surprised me when a few years ago I
heard about this project Natick project
Natick was MSR looking and saying hey
can we go build data centers on the
ocean floor and that just sounded crazy
to me and the idea here is we can drop
tanks onto the ocean floor we can cool
them with the the ambient water cooling
that comes with being on the ocean floor
and the currents we can they actually
the cooling is very efficient because
it's already cold down there and when
you submerge them the other idea is that
you can then have them operate for
longer periods of time you can expand
them very easily because you just drop
additional tanks in the water and so the
first
Natick project was announced publicly a
few years ago there was an article
actually in The New York Times about it
where we dropped just a single rack in a
small cylinder into about 30 feet of
water and we let it sit there for a
month and then they pull it up and it
seemed like things were still working so
we said cool on to the next phase and
this next phase is one that we just
announced about a month ago this is look
at the cylinder here it's about a little
over 12 meters in length about three
meters in diameter
it has 12 racks that are 42 you height
in them and in this build out we've got
about a thousand servers they're
decommissioned Azure servers of course
the the storage has been pulled out and
shredded on the way out of the data
center and so the new there's new hard
disks and SSDs here but they are the
actual same servers that we've been
operating in our Azure data centers the
tubes are built actually at a facility
in France that builds submarines
and they're very good at building these
underwater technologies it takes 30 days
it took 30 days from the finalization of
construction at the plant in France to
this being online at the bottom of the
ocean floor so that shows you the kind
of agility that we might get out of this
expanding capacity when you're double
year over year is a tough problem and if
we can just simply expand on demand
wherever when we need to by simply
shipping a new tank out and having it
deployed within 30 days that will lead
us let us meet that demand very
efficiently this particular
experiment has been done off the Orkney
Islands in northern Scotland the tank
has been shipped out to about a
kilometer offshore and then submerged
into about 100 feet 36 metres of water
and then you can see some pictures here
of it being dropped now one of the
benefits of this so kind of constraints
and kind of interesting problems that
we're looking at here as part of the
research is when the racks are put in
that tube all of the air sucked out of
it and all of the vapor sucked out of as
well and both of these contribute to
corrosive effects on the server's
further once the tube is dropped it is
in a fail in-place mode which means that
as the servers and components fail we
simply let the system degrade and once
it's become degraded enough what we do
is bring another tube another
replacement drop it in the water and
then decommission migrate workloads and
data off of the one that's being that's
degraded on to the new capacity and so a
very efficient way to manage the
server's inside the idea being that the
servers will last longer so our average
server lifetime in a datacenter is
roughly four to five years so we think
this can extend the life cycle of those
servers with because in addition to the
lack of corrosive effects on the
server's there's no maintenance going on
and maintenance disturbs the server's
which can cause problems as well
the PUA that we get out of this so if
you take a look at the typical advanced
state-of-the-art data centers on land
that are designed with traditional
technologies the pu e's are up in the
1.1 plus range the pu e that we expect
on this is about 1.0 3 so this offers
like I said a bunch of a potential
advantages including the energy
efficiency that we get out of this now
let me take a look at as you're
networking now and so if you take a look
at as you're networking it's actually a
very broad set of services and
technologies you can see some of them
listed here by different categories for
example that over in the DC Hardware
space we've got specialized network
hardware including open source software
that we're putting on our switches that
we release to the Open Compute Project
you can see we've got a bunch of
different services that are available to
customers the core one is virtual
networks virtual networks are what the
abstractions that customers bring in
layer IP addresses on top of to connect
their VMs to the virtual machines
together and connect them with our eyes
or services and then you can see we also
as part of that network topology a lock
connection from outside the data center
one of the examples of a service that we
make available to IT customers is
something called Express route which
gives them private connections into our
dark fiber backbone that gives them
highest lays up to 100 gigabits and
dedicated bandwidth into our backbone
and they don't have to then rely on that
ISPs and and the flakiness of the open
Internet speaking of that dark fiber
backbone we've got one of the largest
networks in the world
we've got about over 30,000 miles of
fiber spanning the world you can see a
map this isn't necessarily up-to-date
this is a few months old
but you can get an idea of the kind of
global coverage we've got including
subsea cables that we've laid ourselves
one of the examples is one from Bilbao
to Virginia called Maria that we
launched a couple years ago one of these
subsea cables is a massive capital
expense we went into it with Tulsa Sand
Facebook but all three of us recognizing
that the existing subsea cables
connecting Europe in the u.s. almost all
go from England to New York which
as a potential single point of failure
so in addition to building out an
additional 150 tera bits of capacity
between Europe and the US this gives us
some redundancy with respect to those
failure points of the existing cables
that you can see up there we've also
launched another subsea cable connecting
Asia in the US as well recently in
addition to the dark fiber we also have
4,500 peering connect locations to
connect with other networks around the
world including ISPs and then we also
have 130 edge sites the edge sites are
where we deploy our own software and
servers where we can cache software and
we can run compute on the edge do SSL
termination and give customers that are
using our cloud service is a better
experience we expect those point of
presence sites to also be part of our
third-party edge strategy going forward
so we're looking at that now one of the
aspects of network and I just focused on
the physical aspects in this previous
slide is that networking in the cloud is
what's called software-defined
networking and what saw from many of you
probably are aware of this suffer
Defined Networking became something kind
of well-known about five to seven years
ago we had companies being bought for a
billion dollars because they were
developing suffer defined technologies
the idea here is if you take a look at
traditional IT networking it's been an
appliance model where multiple layers of
this networking stack are combined into
the single appliance those layers are in
the management layer which takes
commands for to configure and deploy
network networks in the data center that
control layer which actually takes those
abstractions that are exposed as api's
and actually translates them into things
like ackles and routing rules and then
the data plane which is programmed with
those ackles and routing rules to honor
what the control plane decides and the
data flows through the data plane of
course with software-defined networking
we take those and spread them out and we
implement them all in software at least
mostly in software I'll get to a caveat
on that in a second if you take a look
at the way we've done this in Azure the
layers aren't the azure resource manager
which is the controlled Universal
control plan for all of the azure api's
if you talk to compute if you talk to
storage if you talk to cosmos DB on the
control plane to create resources and to
configure them you're going through as
your resource manager so when you create
a virtual network you go through as your
resource manager as your resource
manager hands that off to the network
resource provider which implements those
api's and then that calls into network
services that are controllers to go and
set up and define those virtual network
Ackles and routing rules and then it
talks to agents on the servers or the
hosts to implement those rules the idea
here is we want to push as much logic
down the advantages of Software Defined
Networking I kind of obvious here we're
not paying for expensive proprietary
appliances which have reliability issues
they've got scalability issues what we
got here is cloud native layers of the
song of the networking stack from the
top to the bottom that we can expand
that are highly available we can
tolerate massive failures including
failures of availability zones and are
much cheaper to operate now if you take
a look I just mentioned kind of azure
the software-defined networking stack in
the context of azure networking you you
can see the layers here of the whole
azure architecture at a very high level
up at the top there on the far right you
can see the azure portal the command
line interface these are and the SDKs
which talk these management API is a
control plan api's to Azure resource
manager and then you can see some
example services plugged into Azure
resource manager we call those resource
providers like I just mentioned then at
beneath that you've got the as your
fabric controller which is responsible
for launching virtual machines
everything except for a few services at
the very bottom of our architectural
stack runs in virtual machines including
things like Astra database and cosmos
database run in virtual machines there's
a hardware manager that's met the
managers lifecycle of servers and health
of the servers and then the hardware
infrastructure underneath and then you
can see that there's authentication role
based access control telemetry systems
that span the entire software stack now
if we focus just on the networking part
of this
this is a kind of a zoom in on what I
was explaining earlier we've got our
resource manager the network resource
provider and the compute research pilot
or there's no network without compute
and so these work closely together they
work closely together because a customer
says I wanted to find a virtual network
and then I want to place a virtual
machine into that virtual network the
job then of the system is to go find a
computer to put that virtual machine on
and then join that to the virtual
network and so what you'll see is that
these components all meet down on the
server each talking to their own agents
there's a network agent down on the
server there's a compute agent on the
server that launches the virtual machine
the network agent then plumbs the IP
addresses and routing rules into that
virtual machine to have it join this
virtual network so another area where
we've collaborated with Microsoft
Research and this one goes back to a
project that started in MSR about 2010
look one of the MS are researchers Doug
Berger who now as part of the Azure team
in the hardware group he had this vision
that FPGAs had a role in the modern data
center architecture FPGAs have come and
gone throughout time and they fell out
of vogue for over a decade
Doug believed that they had a place and
he took his vision to Bing and started a
project with Bing to see if they could
accelerate the index serving the
indexing of being content on FPGAs that
project pilot was successful and then
deployed into production in Bing now we
faced an issue in Azure about five or
six years ago where we saw networks
going from one gigabit to 10 gigabit on
the servers we saw 40 gigabit coming
50 big gigabits coming next to your 100
gigabits around the corner and if we
when we took a look at us processing
that amount of data on the server's
themselves on the compute servers on the
CPUs we realized that we'd be burning
large amounts of those computers just
doing nothing but packet processing so
the question is how could we do this
more efficiently and how could we keep
up
not just with the bandwidth but keep
latency low for those that amount of
data processing with our network
engineers found out about the Bing
project Doug found out about our problem
and we started to collaborate together
on something called accelerated
networking the idea here is that we take
those FPGAs and just a quick refresh on
FPGAs for those of you that might not
have been around for those previous
phases or just know them and know it
from the acronym there it's there's
small devices with thousands tens of
thousands of logic elements typically
DSP is on them interfaces to the PCIe
bus USB controller and the idea here is
that the interconnect between them is
dynamically programmable within a very
short period of time within a few
milliseconds you can program the
interconnects between these and what
that allows you to do is create a
reconfigurable topology these kinds of
devices because they're some so much
redundancy here of the same kinds of
computational elements that can be
programmed are great for highly parallel
workloads and packet processing is a
highly parallel workload so looking at
these we said hey maybe we can plumb the
Sdn stack into an FPGA effectively
getting close to hardware ASIC
performance but with the flexibility of
being it'll update the algorithms and
the software-defined networking as we go
in fact we have added many many features
dozens of features just in the last
couple years to our Software Defined
Networking stack so we absolutely need
that flexibility we cannot burn to
Software Defined Networking algorithms
into Asics because that would just not
allow us to let the network at large
evolve so what we did is figured out how
to plumb the networking stack into the
FPGA so that in the previous slide where
you talked about the networking agent on
the server's getting those control plane
rules for ackles
and for routes and for IP addresses it
plumbs those into flow tables that are
implemented in soft logic on those FPGAs
and you can see the comparison as we
move to into accelerated networks by
departed deploying fpga into every
single server about three years
go so we're now we think the have the
most deployed FPGAs and production of
any company in the world the left side
of that slide shows you the software
architecture where we're processing
those packets on the host on the servers
and you can see there's a lot of
software layers that we've got to go to
on the right side you can see we bypass
all that allow the virtual machine to
talk directly to a network interface
that's virtualized and provided directly
to that virtual machine so that they can
just talk directly to the hardware and
so there's no computational resources
other than some control plane operations
on the CPUs that allows that frees up
the CPUs of course to do more useful
things like actually run virtual
machines instead of processed packets so
I'm going to show you a quick demo of
those comparison between those two
different technologies here in action
and first I've got a virtual machines
here that I've got without accelerated
networking turned on accelerated
networking is available in all virtual
machines around the world in Azure it's
an opt-in currently because there we
wanted to make sure that there were no
incompatibility issues compatibility
issues with operating systems that
customers use and so right now it's
opt-in soon it will be opted out but on
this virtual machine I have it opted out
what I've done is just set up a receiver
with program called sock curve here's
another virtual machine also opted out
that will talk to that other one and
send it packets as quickly as it can
what we're gonna see after about 15
seconds of run is the latency that these
two virtual machines experience talking
to one another over that
software-defined networking stack as
they're implemented in the host and so
you can see the latency it's about 200
microseconds which isn't bad but let's
go take a look at what accelerator
networking can give us so I've got here
another program and this is using
something called DB DK on a Linux VM
which allows the Linux kernel to process
packets extremely fast with very low
latency so we're going to see something
it looks a little bit better so that's
ten microseconds and so we see typically
latency is between 5 and 10 microseconds
as it compared to about 200 microseconds
on the software-defined stack again with
almost no CPU usage on that versus the
software stack ok let's switch back
alright so let's talk a little bit about
servers now and I'm going to take you on
a tour of history here to show you the
evolution of servers in the cloud
because it's kind of interesting back
when I started in Azure the whole
premise of cloud was cheap commodity
scale-out servers scale up was the
naphtha meta cloud but watch what
happens here's our generation 2 servers
that we launched Azure with in 2010
there are two socket Opterons with 6
CPUs on each socket so a total of 12
cores has 32 gigabytes of RAM and it has
a one gigabit network adapter I'm going
to quickly move through these gen 3 we
jumped to 10 gigabits here's our HPC ski
as we started to introduce what we did
here with their HPC skis which we still
have is InfiniBand 40 gigabit InfiniBand
networking which offers Layton sees that
are even down to one to two microseconds
as opposed to what we see there by the
way that was TCP over InfiniBand it's of
course a different type of network
protocol it's not TCP compatible here we
have our Gen 4 server so you can see
that the amount of RAM that we're
starting to deploy is larger there's
more CPUs and this lets us pack more
virtual machines onto the same servers
then we introduced something called
Godzilla and here's the first example of
a massive scale up this was about three
years ago and what we saw our customers
starting to migrate large in-memory
databases to the cloud
specifically s AP Hana one of the core
workloads in IT is a scale up in memory
database and they needed very large
virtual machines to be able to support
the kinds of computation that their
enterprises ran on so we introduced this
guy it's called Godzilla it has 512 Meg
bites a memory so the largest virtual
machine in these has 450 megabytes of
memory or gigabytes sorry get a memory
Senate not megabytes here's our gen 5.1
so this is what we've been deploying for
the last few years then you can see we
have started to introduce GPUs and these
in turn Vidya GPUs fee 100 SP 40s and
then we introduced this about a year and
a half ago
this we call beast and this one again
customers are migrating even more and
larger si P workloads to the cloud
including Microsoft IT we needed even
larger virtual machines this one has 4
terabytes of RAM and it has 144
processors in it and so this now is what
we've got currently in production is our
large largest VM size you can see our
Gen 6 server this is what we're starting
we're deploying right now into
production and you can see it's got 768
gigabytes of RAM in it so we continue to
rise up in RAM and CPUs and what we just
announced about a month ago is this we
call it beast v2 internally but I think
we should call it mega beast
this thing has 12 terabytes of RAM in it
and so we're the first public cloud to
announced support for 12 terabyte
virtual machines and that of course sa P
workload unblocking as they move to the
cloud so not quite commodity scale out
anymore all of this is built on top of
an open-source platform called project
Olympus project Olympus is designed to
be extremely flexible to support
high-density storage to support SSD hard
disks also to support all the different
kinds of processor technologies we want
to put into the cloud including AMD arm
as well as Intel processors we also
support envied in so we've support
batteries in these servers that power
Ram so that we can tolerate a power
outage that treat that Ram is
non-volatile being able to write it out
to flash before the PI server completely
loses power and this is designed to go
to 50 gigabit NICs like I said we're
already looking at hundred gigabit
coming at us project Olympus actually is
open we contributed to Open Compute
Project so anyone
can go look at these designs and builder
on servers the idea is being that we
innovate with the ecosystem in fact
lympus Gen 6 was the first version of
our server design that we actually took
the initial design out made it available
publicly and sought feedback from all
our hardware partners and so they all
made contributions back into it that
we're then eventually made it into the
final Gen 6 project and lympus platform
now we're also looking at introducing
specialized hardware into our data
centers we've done things like we've
announced Cerberus a specialized
security coprocessor that we put into
our servers but another place that we're
looking at is accelerating deep learning
this is another project led by Doug
Berger focusing on the use of FPGAs for
deep neural networks and his idea here
is again machine learning technologies
changing very quickly so instead of
burning topologies into Asics and having
them be static and rigid and have short
lifetimes if we can leverage FPGAs we
could adapt to new algorithms as they
come up new topologies so the first
version of this is called project brain
wave and we released this into publicly
into public preview at build earlier
this year the idea here of course is
that we can plumb these DNS into FPGAs
these FPGAs are on servers that are
connected with a low latency network and
so we can actually take very large DNS
that don't fit into a single FPGA and
deploy them across multiple servers to
have them operate as basically a
hardware as a service micro service
platform that's Doug's vision now what
we've done I'm going to talk a little
bit about one of the specific use cases
here and that is something called AI for
earth collaboration between us
ESRI and the Chesapeake Conservatory to
go look at land and evaluate how it's
changing with respect to climate change
and other factors traditionally this has
been done by humans and satellite
imageries is captured and then humans go
and look at these images and that decide
how much forestry how much water how
much
urban space is in the image and then we
they track that over time so hundreds of
hours thousands of hours spent by humans
up to now on this now with brainwave we
can take those images the first
algorithm neural network that we
programmed into brain wave is resin at
it's a customizable resin at 50 where
the customer can train their own model
as the final layer and then package that
up even and deploy it on a premise
brainwave but it's deployed as a service
in Azure once the customer trains their
model on top of resin at 50 they
deployed into brain wave VMS and then
can access it through via an API and
that's exactly what this is done this
pipeline shows you I'm going to switch
to a demo to show you brain wave in
action so first I'm going to show you
this Explorer land cover classification
which will show us if I just select one
of these it's going to execute it on
brain wave and inference now brain wave
can infer do inference of an image in
less than two milliseconds and it can
drive through put up to 40 teraflops
tear operations off an FPGA device even
at batch size of one so this is what we
call real-time AI something that's
differentiated from other traditional
batch oriented devices like a GPU or
you've got a feed in one hundred two
hundred images at once to get that kind
of throughput out of the device now
here's the eye for earth app and what
I'm going to do is process these images
using CPU you can see the CPUs
processing about six a second batch
oriented GPU about sixty you can see
that it's progress down here as it
classifies those images and then here's
brainwave and then like I mentioned we
can scale up brainwave so here's
brainwave with 800 roughly 800 FPGAs
so the total data set for the US is
about 195 million images 20 terabytes of
data with brain wave we can process it
in 10 minutes the entire data set for a
cost of about $43 okay let's switch back
so let's talk a little bit about compute
now and here's that high-level Azure
architecture diagram that I showed you
earlier what we're gonna focus on now is
the compute stack and specifically how
we deploy multiple workloads down on to
the platform the azure fabric controller
like I said is responsible for launching
virtual machines but that's typically
not the way that customers using cloud
native technologies will interact with
the platform they will of course use
virtual machines to migrate their
existing IT workloads in a lift and
shift motion but if they're building
something cloud native they're going to
be using containers and container
orchestrators so that's what you can see
here a couple of container orchestrators
kind of the ones that we have bet on one
is called a chaos add your container
service which is kubernetes as a service
kubernetes being the open source
container Orchestrator it's open source
it was developed at Google by three
people in fact one of them Brendan burns
actually works in the azure compute team
so as ER we leverage open source a lot
we contribute to open source a lot and
we've gained a lot of credibility with
the open source community enough that
people can leave oftentimes we see
people wanting to leave Google to come
to Microsoft to work on open source
technologies kind of something that is
shocking for people that have watched
Microsoft over the last two decades now
the other service you can see here is
called service fabric this is what
technology we developed internally and
that most of our cloud services are
built on top of most of the azure
infrastructure is built on top of this
micro service platform which can also do
container orchestration but it's unique
in that it supports stateful services so
it's tightly integrated its Federation
model its health model to be highly
scalable and to support the
highly durable storage of data and when
you take a look at a service like cosmos
DB which is built on top of this cosmos
TB is replicating data three through
copies of each database and so with
tight coordination with the fabric the
service fabric controller on health on
upgrades service Robert can make sure
that that data is always available for
write operations in the face of failures
and reconfigurations and service fabric
is something that if you take a look
actually let me back up here and come
back to service fabric in a second a
deeper dive into I thought I'd show you
just the complexity that we've gotten to
in the orchestration of something that
seems as simple as deploying a virtual
machine in the cloud here you can see
all of the resource providers are at
least most of the resource providers and
some of the services regional services
that are involved with the deployment of
virtual machine which includes compute
network and storage and you can see
we've got the idea of clusters down
clusters with cluster managers that
manage groups of servers so tenant
manager that's TM data center manager
manages the hardware for cluster Network
Service Manager software load balancer
all of those are basically cluster level
services they manage a slice of an
entire data center of a region and then
down on the servers we've got agents
corresponding to each of these and when
we deploy a virtual machine here's the
kind of flows that you see of these
services talking to each other
communicating data so that we can
finally I'll end up with a virtual
machine down on the server that has a
network and storage attached to it but
going back to service fabric which is
layered on top of this where the world
is going as something called service
technology so we went from containers a
few years ago which was all the rage
then the container orchestrators and
micro service platforms and paths on top
of micro services and then now what we
see is the next level of abstraction and
productivity which is built on top of
service technologies service really
pioneered by functions as service we
have got our own functions as a service
called as our functions the idea here
being the developer dress rights a piece
of code they
give it to the cloud platform and we
take care of everything else we take of
auto-scaling we take care of the
reliability of it they focus just on the
code and they pay for only the resources
consumed by that piece of code so they
specify I want this much RAM for this
code and we bill only for the amount of
CPU consumed by the code so if the code
never runs the functions registered
nothing ever happens they don't get
charged anything if they a thousand
invitations of that function happen and
they each run for a minute then they get
build a thousand compute minutes and so
it's paper use and really great for
bursty type of workloads it's also a
vent driven model that is now becoming
very popular in the cloud each of these
functions is triggered by some event for
example some image beings dropped into a
storage account could kick off a
function that then calls into brainwave
to go to inference on that image but
what we've got with service fabric is
we're taking that service concept and
expanding it to general-purpose micro
services to general platform not just
event-driven micro functions in this
case we just announced the public
preview of this service service fabric
mesh and service fabric mesh is service
service Robert so you can actually take
description of a micro service
application it's even stateful built
with even abstract programming models
like the actor model and give it to us
and we will go and launch it on we'll
take care of the provisioning the
virtual machines will launch those
containers onto them and then you get
paid only for the execution those
containers and never have to worry about
the infrastructure only we'll focus on
the containers and so this is where the
world is going is this kind of
developers only worry about their code
and the platform takes care of
everything else we're at the next phase
of this and there's still a lot of work
to do in this now to highlight one of
the very productive collaborations we've
had with Microsoft research we've been
collaborating with Microsoft Research on
the problem of resource allocation in
our data centers for last it since close
to when I joined as about eight years
ago including Microsoft Asia one of the
key researchers there in fact we hired
him in
about a year and a half ago he was
instrumental in this the collaboration
with Microsoft research continues on
this project called research central
which is generally looking at how do we
make use of resources in general more
efficient and that efficiency comes in a
number of different forms how do we pack
virtual machines more tightly and not
waste resources on on servers how do we
make sure that an Invicta below doesn't
interfere with the placement of an on
evict above higher priority workload how
do we make sure that we don't exceed
power budgets in our data centers as CPU
spins up all of these are questions that
we want to get better insights into out
of resource central and if you take a
look at resource central it's heavily
dependent on machine learning algorithms
taking in data and historical data from
production training on that data and
then generating models that we then
deploy as offline services that are
integrated with the online resource
allocator and they're offline in the
sense that the the system the running
system does not depend on the
availability of those services these are
optimizations one of the principles in
the cloud is you don't want as you want
as few dependencies on the runtime
operation of the service as possible
because failures always happen and if
there's a non-critical component you
don't want to put that in the hot path
but you can look at the problems that
we're looking at virtual machine
scheduling which clusters virtual
machines go to I mentioned power
oversubscription how we do server
maintenance in an efficient way without
impacting customers or minimally
impacting customers and then even giving
customers right-sizing recommendations
based on looking at historical patterns
of other virtual machines that they
might be running other ones that are
running similar workloads their
historical of usage of resources by that
particular virtual machine we can say
hey looks like you could easily fit into
a virtual machine that's much smaller or
you need more resources actually because
your bottleneck
here's just one example of one of the
projects that we've had ongoing and I
say ongoing because these are never kind
of ending projects
there's always room for more
optimization and as Donnell mentioned
one percent of optimization in the right
place can have huge impact when you're
talking about millions of virtual
machines and you're talking about
millions of servers saving 1% of your
resource can literally mean millions of
dollars and so this resource allocation
algorithm that we've developed with MSR
assigns each resource dimension assigns
it a weight which is relative to the
scarcity of that resource and then runs
this optimization problem where we try
to maximize the availability of those
scarce resources through our allocations
you can see there on the right to
example allocations obviously the one on
the right is a better one for this
particular server if we allocate too low
vert so much low memory machines meaning
they consume a lot of course but little
memory we waste a bunch of memory on
that server but if we take one of those
low memory machines take another one
that's not consuming as many CPU cores
so we've got additional CPU cores
they're left for virtual machine that is
a high memory virtual machine few cores
relative to them on a ram we can
actually make use of all the resources
on that server so that's just a simple
look at the optimization problem here's
another example where we take a look at
historical eviction patterns for virtual
machines and use them to influence the
allocation algorithm so we've got two
virtual machines a and we know B is
gonna be coming B is a full server
virtual machine a is a 1/4 virtual
machine and there's two servers that
we've got to pick from to allocate this
both can fit this virtual machine a and
the question is which of these is the
better fit if the probability that a
virtual machine is going to terminate by
time T when we need allocate virtual
machine B is one half and you can see
the probability if we deploy that
virtual machine a on node one well the
probability of it terminating those two
VMs that are then on node one
terminating by time T is one half
squared the probability of one of those
three virtual machines all three
terminating on node 2 to make room for
that virtual machine B is 1/2 to the
third and you can see that so the
problem
at time t that we'll be able to allocate
bridge machine B is six over sixteen but
if we place the virtual machine on node
two our odds get better that virtual
machine B will find a home so that's
another example of the kind of resource
allocation strategies that we've
developed in conjunction with MSR and
you can see we've used a bunch of
different machine learning algorithms
depending on the problem for CP
utilization modeling random forest for
lifetime the virtual machine gradient
boosting trees and the accuracy of these
models is we developed them is extremely
high high enough of course that we are
they are having a significant impact on
our efficiency in the data center so let
me now switch to Azure storage and Azure
storage there's three layers in the
architecture roughly so you can see the
front ends there you can see a partition
layer which partitions the data and then
you can see a distributed file system
layer which handles what are called
streams for those partitions and that
layer is the one that actually does the
replication the others are effectively
the control plane and the DFS layer is
the data plane for the storage service
on top of this we've got load balancers
and then the storage service exposes a
number of different api's it exposes a
simple blobby API in both block blob and
paged blob forms page blobs something
that we use for a virtual machine hard
disk so page blobs are fixed the page is
fixed in size a block blob is arbitrary
size queues which are simple FIFO queues
file API which it includes SMB as well
as HDFS we recently announced as well
and these storage services support
replication across regions so if you
deployed something with regional geo
replication RA GRS then what you've got
or the partition layers doing
replication now like many of the pieces
of azure that we started with ten years
ago
we've had to reelect the system as we've
gotten to larger and larger scale the
initial storage architecture was based
on these storage stamps or clusters a
fixed number of virtue of physical
servers and what you've got when you've
got a large data center or a region with
many many stamps is inefficiencies
inefficiencies and scale limits the
scale limits are the limits of the
server's in that one stamp are the
maximum limits that we can offer
customers for throughput and size of
their data of their storage service and
then it's inefficient in terms of the
fragmentation because we've got to have
failure buffers in each cluster we've
got a big expansion buffers in each
cluster and we can't amortize those
buffers across all of the servers in the
in the data center region so we aree
architect to started really tackling the
storage system about two and a half
years ago three years ago actually and
we just put our putting this into
production now this is called gen to
Azure data Lake storage and it we call
it internally limitless storage because
if you take a look at some of the scale
limits so a storage account limit and
we're gonna see these limits even go up
50 gigabytes per second as opposed to
the 60 megabytes per second that we used
to have the throughput spikes are
instantaneous and there's no warm-up for
these and the scale we can effectively
our target is that one storage blob
could consume every single byte of
storage in an entire region that's the
kind of scale limits we're going to so
basically that's hence the name
limitless you can see that the
throughput now that we can drive off of
be able to take advantage as a much
scale-out storage as servers as possible
in this architecture we can go from
uploading a five terabyte blob that used
to take 14 minutes to uploading one
sorry in 14 minutes that previously took
you can see 12 hours so massive
improvement in the kind of throughput
that we get with this new architecture
but we're also looking with MSR at the
future of storage
we've got hard disks we've got SSDs we
also have tape now and we've got also
something called Pelican a project where
we've got hard disks in basically hard
disk appliance form a rack of hard disks
where only some of the hardest can be
spun up at a time as a low-cost archival
storage solution with higher latency
than a single hard disk solution but we
want to do better it's all about
maximizing efficiency especially for
archival storage which can be around for
long periods of time with never without
ever being accessed you want that to be
as cheap as possible the world is now
storing massive amounts of data and so
we've got two projects going on with MSR
one is called silica and it's looking at
glass and I'll explain that one another
one's called pale X and it's looking at
use of DNA to store data I don't have
time to talk about pale X this morning
but that's another very exciting project
that offers the promise of storing a
full zettabyte of data in a single rack
in a data center and just to put that
into perspective the estimate is that
there's around 20 zettabytes of data on
the planet today so 20 racks and you
could store all the data in the world on
pail X going to glass let me talk a
little bit about this is a project with
the University of Southampton
collaboration with MSR Cambridge there
and us in an azure idea here is to store
data in glass obviously now that might
seem straightforward just etched the
data into the glass the problem is up to
now there's been no way to efficiently
store data high density in glass because
whenever somebody tries to etch it with
lasers they end up with defects the
defects caused by material deformations
because the laser pulses are damaging
the atomic structure of the glass and so
you might write something but you can't
read it back so what the University of
Southampton and Microsoft Research have
been working on are using high speed
lasers that operate at the femtosecond
range which is the same kind of pulse
duration that you might have cataract
surgery with or
or lend surgery and how long is the
femtosecond it's it's really short I had
to look it up and with a femtosecond
laser we can pulse and generate what are
called voxels in the glass which are
three-dimensional structures you can see
here that have some depth and by
targeting laser at different depths in
the glass we can create multiple layers
of this in one piece of glass fact I was
given a sample yesterday by the project
silica team that has 76 layers in it so
we've gotten now where we can store very
efficiently vertically as well as
horizontally with five microns
separation between these voxels and
here's a look at the reader for this the
interesting thing about glass is once
you write it you never have to refresh
it it lasts for literally millions of
years longer or billions of years really
so outlasting even probably the earth
and you don't need a specialized reader
you don't need to specialized reading
technology to read it all you need is
light so flashing light on this and
looking at the reflections of light or
how that light is diffracting out those
voxels you can read the data off of it
and so this is a look at a read head you
can see that this one is going through
20 layers showing a simple image of
those 20 layers so each of those depths
and then here's a look at how we decode
the data we take multiple images at a
layer using different conditions and
then we look at the retardant sand
orientation and then map that to
orientation and retardant where we can
encode data in those two values and you
can see here an example of a three bit
per box 'el example of encoding data on
that glass what this promises in terms
of density too is storing about 50
terabytes of data in two centimeter
square so this is orders of magnitude
more dense than the kinds of archival
data that we have out now this would be
a huge breakthrough for our
storage and it's one of those long-term
kinds of projects we got MSR it's
multiple years significant amount of
investment of course in material
technology and equipment that needs to
be taken from a lab prototype and then
made data center production ready and
we're all doing it in collaboration so
that brings me the conclusion at a talk
here I gave you a brief overview of
high-level Azure architecture some a
look at some of the interesting MSR
projects the the bottom line is that
when it comes to research in the cloud
besides of course innovative programming
models innovative topologies
communications architectures much of the
research that we focus on is driving up
efficiency and scale and performance and
you can look at the projects that I
showed you they're all aimed at
efficiency scale and performance they're
just some of the projects that we've got
going with MSR I mentioned pay licks
we've got another one optical networking
called Sirius we've got another one that
you're going to hear about here if you
go to Albert Greenberg's talk on crystal
net which is simulating our wide area
network so that we can make
configuration changes safely the list
goes on and on and it's like I said it's
a competitive advantage of us to have
MSR here to go out and explore these
kinds of areas in some cases ones that
seem far-fetched to us when we initially
look at them and offer a bunch of
research problems like project Natick
that if they are realized could really
transform our business so with that I
want to wrap it up I again I want to
thank Eric and Donald and Dan for
inviting me to open up this faculty
summit with you I hope you have got a
fantastic few days here a bunch of
interesting talks you've got ahead of
you and thank you very much
[Applause]
much
[Music]
you